c'est quand même complètement débile de
m'être fait connaître avec une guitare
alors que je sa pas du tout en
jouer alors du coup tout le monde me
demande toujours des chansons et puis
évidemment tout le monde se rend bien
compte que je sais pas du tout en
faire je me sens un petit peu comme un
mec qui aurait gagné les votes du public
pour devenir président alors qu'à la
base il est juste conseiller au Crédit
Agricole récment on m'a même proposé euh
euh de représenter la France au concours
de
l'Eurovision si ils m'ont dit ouais euh
comme tu es belge et que c'est un petit
peu la merde en France est-ce que tu
voudrais pas faire une petite
déclaration d'amour à la France pour
donner un peu une image un petit peu
positive et ça m'a touché parce que
c'est vrai qu'en Belgique on voit ça de
l'extérieur et franchement on a de la
peine pour
vous non je déconne on se sout de votre
gueule